>>> THE MORNING ENCOURAGING
SIGNS OUT OF THE UK.
NEW CORONAVIRUS CASES THERE ARE
PLUNGING AFTER THE COUNTRY
EXPERIENCED A SPIKE BECAUSE OF
THE DELTA VARIANT.
CNN'S PHIL BLACK LIVE IN LONDON
WITH MUCH MORE ON THIS.
PHIL, THE BIG QUESTION IS, HOW?
WHY?
>> Reporter: INDEED, JOHN.
LAST WEEK WHEN ENGLAND THREW
AWAY THE PANDEMIC RULE BOOK AND
DECLARED SO-CALLED FREEDOM DAY,
THE EXPECTATION WAS THINGS ARE
GOING TO GET MUCH WORSE.
THE SCIENTIFIC MODELLING SHOWED
THE EXISTING SURGE WOULD GET
BIGGER AND STRONGER, BUT SINCE
THEN, THIS EXTRAORDINARY THING
HAS HAPPENED.
CASES HAVE FALLEN RAPIDLY.
AND NO ONE REALLY KNOWS WHY.
♪♪
>> Reporter: IN THE FIRST WEEK
OF ENGLAND'S HANDS OFF, MOSTLY
UNRESTRICTED POLICY OF LIVING
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS, SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY HAS HAPPENED.
THE UK'S GROWING WAVE OF CASES
HAS SUDDENLY, UNEXPECTEDLY
FALLEN AWAY.
THE DROP HAS BEEN QUICK AND
DRAMATIC.
COMPARED TO THE PREVIOUS WEEK
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF CONFIRMED
CASES IS DOWN 36%.
SCIENTISTS ADMIT, NO ONE SAW
THIS COMING.
>> IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT I
EXPECTED OR PREDICTED.
>> I THINK IT SURPRISED A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT HAS COME DOWN THIS
QUICKLY, THIS MUCH IN SIN CRONY.
>> THEY ONLY HAVE THEORIES ON
WHY THIS IS HAPPENING.
THE END OF THE EUROPEAN SOCCER
CHAMPIONSHIPS MEANS NO MORE BIG
EMOTIONAL CROWDS.
A RECENT STRETCH OF GOOD WEATHER
ENCOURAGED PEOPLE TO STAY
OUTSIDE.
SCHOOLS ARE OUT FOR SUMMER,
CLOSING WHAT SOME SCIENTISTS
BELIEVE IS A SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENT FOR TRANSMISSION.
AWARENESS OF SURGING CASES MAY
HAVE INSPIRED MORE CAUTIOUS
BEHAVIOR.
AND THERE'S ALSO THE POSSIBILITY
VAST NUMBERS OF PEOPLE ARE STILL
BEING INFECTED, THEY'RE JUST NOT
FOLLOWING UP WITH TESTS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T WANT TO CANCEL PLANS
AND STAY AT HOME.
>> SO THE ISSUE IS WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN TERMS OF REDUCTION IN
CASES A TRUE REFLECTION OF THE
COMMUNITY LEVELS OF INFECTION?
>> Reporter: SCIENTISTS FEEL
CONFIDENT ON ONE POINT, VACCINES
ARE HELPING BUT IT'S TOO SOON TO
ATTRIBUTE THE DROP TO HERD
IMMUNITY.
>> WE NEED TO REMEMBER, ONLY 55%
OF OUR POPULATION ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
THE REST ARE EITHER PARTIALLY
VACCINATE ORD NOT VACCINATED AT
ALL.
>> Reporter: THE DELAY BETWEEN
INFECTION AND SYMPTOMATIC
ILLNESS MEANS DOES NOT AFFECT
THE CONSEQUENCES OF ENGLAND
THROWING AWAY THE PANDEMIC RULES
JULY 19th.
>> IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE DON'T
ALLOW OURSELVES TO RUN AWAY WITH
PREMATURE CONCLUSIONS ABOUT
THIS.
>> Reporter: BUT THE SUDDEN
CHANGES ARE FUELING HOPE THE UK
WILL NOT EXPERIENCE THE GRIM,
DIFFICULT SUMMER MANY PREDICTED.
SO, IS THIS REAL?
IS THIS A BLIP?
IS IT A NEW, SUSTAINED TREND?
SCIENTISTS SAY THEY WILL BE
STUDYING HOSPITAL ADMISSION
FIGURES IN THE COMING WEEKS.
IF THIS IS A REAL SIGNIFICANT
DROP IN INFECTIONS, YOU SHOULD
SEE REDUCED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
FALLING ILL AND AT THE MOMENT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE STILL GOING
UP, JOHN.
>> WE'RE WATCHING, WAITING AND
FRANKLY, PHIL, HOPING BASED ON
WHERE WE ARE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT WE CAN FOLLOW THAT
EXAMPLE IF IT'S REALLY IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
PHIL BLACK, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW IS THE UK
AMBASSADOR TO THE UNITED STATES.
AMBASSADOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> HOW ARE YOU VIEWING THIS
PHENOMENON AND HOW IS THE
BRITISH GOVERNMENT VIEWING IT?
>> WELL, WE'RE CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC.
WE'RE CONSCIOUS WE DON'T HAVE
ALL THE DATA YET.
WE BELIEVE IT HAS SOMETHING TO
DO WITH GOOD MESSAGING, PEOPLE
FOLLOWING SENSIBLE RULES ON
BEHAVIOR, LIKE HAND WASHING AND
OF COURSE A HIGH VACCINATION
RATE.
BUT WE NEED MUCH MORE
INFORMATION BEFORE WE CAN
PROPERLY ANALYZE THIS AND WORK
OUT WHAT THE FUTURE TREND WILL
BE.
>> YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HERE
IS ARE YOU DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT THAN WE ARE?
WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT THE UK
THAN THE UNITED STATES?
ONE OF THE THINGS YOU MENTIONED
TO US IS, YOU'RE A BRIT LIVING
IN THE UNITED STATES RIGHT NOW,
SO YOU HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
IN THE UNITED KINGDOM THERE'S
NOT THE ANTI-VAX SENTIMENT THAT
THERE IS HERE.
EXPLAIN.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE ARE SOME COMMUNITIES THAT
RESIST GETTING THE VIRUS.
AND RESIST GETTING THE VACCINE.
WE RELY ON PEER PRESSURE AND
LOCAL LEADERSHIP AND PUBLIC
MESSAGING TO BRING THOSE
COMMUNITIES AROUND.
BUT ON THE WHOLE, THE NUMBERS
ARE VERY GOOD.
70% OF ADULTS HAVE BEEN FULLY
VACCINATED.
90% HAVE GOT ONE DOSE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO PUSH OUT
MESSAGING ABOUT HAND WASHING,
GOOD BEHAVIOR, WEARING MASKS IN
CROWD.
WE'RE NOT DROPPING ALL THE RULES
BUT WE ARE BEING CAREFUL AND
CAUTIOUS AND OPENING UP.
>> 90% -- ALMOST 90% DEPENDING
ON THE COUNTRY WHEREVER YOU ARE,
BUT THAT'S HUGE WHEN YOU COMPARE
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH IN THE
U.S.
BRITAIN IS NOW ALLOWING
AMERICANS AND EUROPEANS WHO ARE
FULLY VACCINATED TO COME INTO
BRITAIN AND NOT HAVE TO
QUARANTINE.
AND I KNOW THAT BRITAIN IS
LOOKING TO THE UNITED STATES TO
DO THE SAME THING.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT THE U.S.
RECIPROCATE?
>> WE WERE PLEASED TO MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY.
AS YOU SAY WE WILL ALLOW
AMERICANS WHO ARE FULLY
VACCINATED INTO THE UK WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS.
THEY WILL NEED TO SHOW PROOF OF
LIVING IN AMERICA.
THEY WILL NEED TO SHOW THEIR CDC
CARD.
THEY WILL NEED TO TAKE A TEST
BEFORE THEY LEAVE AND A TEST
WHEN THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR TWO
DAYS.
I CAN SAY SO NO ONE GETS
CONFUSED BY THE RULES, ANYONE
WHO WANTS TO GO CAN GO ON TO
WWW.GOV/UK.
WE HAVE A TASK FORCE WORKING ON
THIS WITH THE ADMINISTRATION.
SET UP AFTER THE PRESIDENT
VISITED THE UNITED KINGDOM IN
JUNE.
WE KNOW YOU'RE NOT READY TO LIFT
THAT ORDER YET.
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER PARTLY
BECAUSE OF VACCINATION RATES.
BUT WE CONTINUE TO LOOK AT ALL
THE DETAIL, ALL THE
TECHNICALITIES AND TRY TO WORK
OUT WITH OUR AMERICAN COLLEAGUES
HOW WE COULD GET A TRAVEL
CORRIDOR OF SOME SORT GOING.
WE REALLY WANT TO OPEN UP TO
BUSINESS AND INTERNATIONAL
TRAVEL.
>> ONE OF THE REQUIREMENTS IS
PROOF OF VACCINATION.
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
THERE'S MORE OF A WILLINGNESS
FOR IN THE UNITED KINGDOM THAN
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE THESE COVID PASSPORTS
IN A WAY.
WHAT RIGHTS, YOU KNOW, WHAT DOES
THIS GET YOU INTO?
WHAT DOORS DOES IT OPEN WHEN YOU
HAVE PROOF OF VACCINATION IN THE
UNITED KINGDOM?
>> AT THE MOMENT DOCUMENT WHOSE
USE IS BEING DEVELOPED.
FROM SEPTEMBER, THERE WILL BE
VENUES LIKE NIGHTCLUBS THAT WILL
REQUIRE PEOPLE TO BE FULLY
VACCINATED.
SO THAT PASSPORT WILL BE USEFUL
FOR THAT.
BUT AT THE MOMENT, WE'RE WORKING
OUT WHAT VENUES, WHAT LARGE
EVENTS, WHAT LARGE CROWDED
EVENTS A PASSPORT MIGHT BE
USEFUL FOR.
>> IT IS LIKE A DIFFERENT WORLD
IN A WAY FROM THE COUNTRY THAT
WE ARE LIVING IN WITH THE